reactive X has revolutionized the way
modern developers think about building
apps it allows us to treat all data as a
stream as it unfolds through the
dimension of time in this lesson I'm
going to cover about 25 different ways
you can use our XJS so you have a solid
foundation to use it in your own
projects for this tutorial I've just
created a basic HTML page and imported
the rxjs script from a CDN in the head
of that page then we'll write all of our
custom code in this lesson J's file and
import that in the body of the page then
inside lesson Jas I'm creating a helper
function that will just append the
results from an observable to the
browser on the right side here so when
you see me use the print function it's
to add the values to the browser here on
the right the first thing we're going to
talk about is the observable and I think
the easiest way to think about it is
just an array that gets built over time
and you can loop over this array in the
dimension of time by subscribing to it
the first thing we're gonna do is create
an observable from scratch
we do this by calling our X dot
observable create and then create takes
a observer function where we can define
what the observable sends to the
subscriber to send values you call
observer next with the value you want to
send and that value can be anything it
could be a string and object or whatever
you want then to make the observable
start emitting values you call subscribe
on it in this case we'll take each value
and just print it to the screen if we
refresh our page you can see we get
hello world print it to the screen so
that's pretty cool but we don't normally
need to create observables manually like
this let's say we wanted to create an
observable from click events in the Dom
we can call observable from event pass
at the document and the event we want to
observe in this case clicks so just like
before we subscribe to it but at this
time we'll console.log it just to show
the full event object each time we click
the page we get the mouse event logged
along with all of its associated data if
you work with asynchronous JavaScript
you're probably used to working with
promises and we can convert a promise
directly into an observable so here
we're just creating a promise with a
timeout that resolves after one second
the idea here is to simulate an API call
or some other asynchronous operation to
convert this promise to an observable we
just call observable from promise and
pass it the promise this is extremely
useful when you're
working with a JavaScript library that's
built on promises you can also convert
the observable back to a promise by
calling to promise on it so when we
subscribe to this observable we get a
one-second delay and then it prints
resolved on the page we can also create
a timer by calling observable timer with
the amount of milliseconds we want to
wind it up for to start the timer we
just call subscribe on it and then it
will emit a value once the timer runs
out so we refresh the page and one
second later our timer runs out if we
want a timer that keeps repeating we can
use an interval which emits a value
after the specified time frame so every
1000 milliseconds we'll get a new value
emitted in this case here we'll print
out a date with the number of seconds in
the minute to show how this works we
reload the page and then every second we
get a new value emitted from the
observable now I'm going to show you one
last way to create an observable there's
actually more ways than this but I think
this covers the basics for now so we'll
do observable of which allows us to pass
any static value we want to be
observable so we'll go ahead and pass it
a string and array a number a boolean
and an object this example shows how any
type of data can be a stream which is an
important concept to keep in mind when
building reactive software the next
concept will look at is hot versus cold
observables a cold observable is
basically just an observable where the
data is created inside of it so this
means it won't actually create the
underlying data until something
subscribes to it inside this observable
I'm just generating a random number and
then I'll create two different
subscribers and you might intuitively
think that they should get the same
value but what happens is the random
number gets generated once the
subscription starts so each subscriber
gets a different number that's how you
know you're working with a cold
observable but you can make an
observable hot by simply building that
value outside of the observable itself
so here we set the random number outside
the observable and then pass it in as a
variable reload the page and then we'll
see both subscribers get the same random
number that technically makes our
observable hot but there is a way to do
this without decoupling the data from
the observable itself so we'll put the
random number back in the observable
then
will create a new hot observable by
calling publish on the cold observable
this tells it only to emit data once we
called a corresponding connect method on
it so we'll build the subscriptions and
at this point nothing will happen then
call connect on the hot observable and
that will trigger these subscriptions to
emit data and this time it'll be shared
between the two of them and we can
verify this by reloading the page and
they should get the same random number
the next thing you should know is how to
complete an observable when the
observable has reached the end of its
life cycle it will send a completed
signal we can see this with a timer
using the finally operator which will
run the code once the observable is
completed in this case it will be
completed after one second so we
subscribe and then we get the all done
signal back however there are other
observables that won't complete
automatically and in some cases this can
result in memory leaks if it's a very
data-intensive stream here we have an
interval which doesn't complete on its
own so what we do is subscribe to it
first then set a timeout for three
seconds and call unsubscribe this
manually forces the observable to send
the complete signal there's also more
clever ways to do this which we're going
to see a little bit later in the lesson
now we're going to look at a whole bunch
of rxjs operators starting with map map
allows you to transform the emitted
value based on some underlying logic in
this case we created an observable of
some numbers and we're going to
transform them to their logarithm so
when we subscribe instead of getting the
actual numbers we get the log of that
number a more practical example for app
developers is when you send an API
request that responds in JSON you need
to convert the JSON string to JavaScript
so what you can do is use the map
operator to run json.parse on that
string from the API then the observable
will you met JavaScript objects that you
can actually use in your app the next
operator we're going to look at is do
this will allow us to execute code
without affecting the underlying
observable so we create observable of a
couple strings and then we'll print out
their names as they first appear then
we'll transform them to uppercase and
then we'll print them again when we
actually run this code you can see that
it gives us a glimpse into the
observable data at any given point in
time so here we see the
value and the upper case value now let's
take a look at filter this does pretty
much what you'd expect you give it a
condition and only values meeting that
condition make it through so here we
have an observable of a bunch of
positive and negative numbers and we'll
filter it to only show the positive
numbers so only value is greater than or
equal to zero will be displayed and we
reload the page and we only see the
positive numbers if we flip greater than
to less than then we get only the
negative numbers displayed using this
same example I'm going to show you the
first and last operator the first
operator will just take the very first
element from the observable in this case
the first element is negative three so
that's what we see here on the screen we
can also do the inverse of this with the
last operator and negative two is the
last element so we'll see it updated to
negative two now let's take a look at D
balance and throttle these two operators
allow you to deal with events that you
met way more values than you actually
need
the mousemove event is a perfect example
in the Dom so we'll subscribe to the
mouse event and then we'll print the
type of event here on the screen let's
first do this without any throttling or
debouncing you can see it only takes
about two seconds to get hundreds of
events printed here on the screen we can
use throttle to get the very first event
and then set a delay before it starts
emitting any other events in this case
we'll use the throttle time helper and
pass it 1000 milliseconds so now if we
mouse over the screen we'll get the
first event and then it will wait at
least one second before sending any
additional events debounce does almost
the same exact thing but instead of
giving us the first event it gives us
the last event so first we mouse over
and there's a delay then after that
delay it will emit the most recent event
debounce is especially useful when you
want to make sure the user is stopped
doing something such as typing in an
autocomplete form or something similar
now we're going to move on to the scan
operator this one seems confusing at
first but it's actually very simple
we're going to do this in the context of
a video game so first we're gonna
subscribe to the click events in the
browser and then for each click we're
gonna assign a random number that's
going to represent the score for that
click
then we'll use the do operator to print
that score on the screen and then will
you scan to keep a running total of the
high score which is just the combined
score up all the clicks so scan is just
keeping a running total of each emitted
value from the observable it works just
like the array reduced function and
vanilla JavaScript so we'll go ahead and
print out the high score here and we
should see it get increasingly larger
with each additional click so on that
first click the high score and the click
score are the same and then the high
score gets increasingly larger with each
additional click now let's move on to
switch map this operator is especially
useful when you have one observable that
you need a value from before you can get
a second observable in this example we
have an observable of clicks but we
actually don't care about the click data
we want to start an interval timer after
each click so on the first click the
interval should start and then when we
get a new click it'll reset the interval
back to zero
so we'll go ahead and click the page and
then we'll let the interval count up to
6 and then click again and it'll reset
back to zero
switch map is commonly used in app
development when you have an observable
of say a user ID and then you need that
user ID first before querying a database
for that users data the next operator is
take until this one allows us to
complete an observable based on the
value of another observable so here we
have an interval and a timer the
interval is going to emit values every
500 milliseconds until the timer runs
out after 2 seconds this is a clever way
to unsubscribe from data without
actually having to call unsubscribe on
the observable itself so here we get the
first few emitted values then the timer
runs out and so it logs complete a
closely related operator is take while
this one will tell the observable to
emit values until a certain condition
turns true in this example we have a
collection of names and we want to stop
the observable once it reaches the name
of dugg in other words we want it to
take values while the name does not
equal done then we'll use the finally
operator to verify that the observable
completed successfully
so when we run this in the browser we
can see we only get the values that came
before Doug now let's look at a few ways
we can can
observables starting with zip zip is
something that might be useful if you
have two observables that are the same
length and connected in some kind of way
so here we have observables yin and yang
and we're going to combine them with zip
which will combine them into arrays
based on their index position in the
observable so peanut butter will be
matched with jelly wine with cheese
rainbows with unicorns another way to
merge observables is with fork join this
one will wait for both of the
observables to complete and then it will
combine the last two values together so
I'm going to put a delay on the yang
observable then we'll use the fork join
operator to combine them just like zip
but at this time we should see a
two-second delay and then only the last
two values rainbows and unicorns should
be emitted this operator is useful if
you have a bunch of related API calls
and you want to wait for all of them to
resolve before sending any data through
to the UI now we're going to look at
catch for handling errors in this
example I create a new observable from
scratch but in the middle of it I throw
an error when we get errors in the real
world we want to be able to catch them
and then do some error handling in this
case we'll use the catch operator to
complete the observable and just print
out the error so notice that we get the
first three values in the observable but
the very last one doesn't get emitted
overall the idea is very similar to how
promises work in JavaScript we also have
a useful retry operator that will rerun
the observable as many times as we want
when an error is occurred so right after
catch we can add retry and in this case
we'll retry it twice when we run it this
time we'll get the same sequence of
events but they'll happen three times
the initial run plus the two retries so
that's all the operators I'm gonna cover
for today there's tons more in rxjs but
I think these are some of the most
useful and powerful ones that you'll
find we just have one more topic to
cover and that's the rxjs subject a
subject is just an observable with a few
extra bonus features it has the ability
to emit new data to its subscribers by
acting as a proxy to some other data
source this will make more sense after
the next couple
samples so here we have a plain
observable and we're going to convert it
to a subject when we subscribe to it it
emits the values just like a normal
observable would but the real benefit of
subject is to be able to call next on it
so what we do is create a new subject
and then we'll create us a couple of
subscriptions to it and then we can just
call subject next with some value that's
not something you can do on a normal
observable then we'll set another next
call inside of a timeout so the main
benefit of a subject is being able to
broadcast new values to subscribers
without having to rely on some source
data to build on this topic we're gonna
look at one last thing and that's
multicast it's used to send values to
multiple subscribers but not any related
side effects so we create a data source
that is the click events happening in
the DOM and then we use the do operator
to print do one time this is an example
of a side effect imagine we had a
hundred subscribers it would run this
code for every single one a bomb so if
you had a hundred clicks and a hundred
subscribers this code would run 10,000
times
well we actually want is for it to only
run on the 100 clicks coming from the
source observable we can do this by
calling multicast on the original
observable and have it return a new
subject then we can add a couple of
subscriptions to the subject then lastly
we need to call connect on that subject
when we start clicking in the Dom we'll
see that we get the values sent to the
subscribers and the side effect only
runs once even though there's multiple
subscribers this could be highly
beneficial if you have multiple
subscribers to a single data source that
is running some sort of side effect
that's it for my rxjs QuickStart if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and if you want to get the
full source code and additional
commentary head over to angular firebase
com
thanks for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]